okay so it's time to introduce our first
guest and i don't know who it is um i
hope they like margaritas and cases and
if they don't leave
please welcome the star of one of my
favorite shows on television come on out
whoever you are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
so basically
i'm on a date drinking with nathan
filling that's what's happening i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i am i have no
idea i literally have nothing no idea we
wanted to surprise you okay okay but i
didn't want this to be the only surprise
oh it's enough can i bring some more oh
yeah or please say okay i want to you
guys to all welcome please welcome uh
makia cox
alyssa diaz melissa o'neil and erica
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so vic would you mind running
over some chips and drinks to the entire
cost of the rookie
i'm so excited i'm sweating
i'm sweating i have my drink very much
unfortunately i can't oh my gosh y'all
don't dive into the rookie unless you're
in for the long haul hello it is so good
you're welcome
i got so addicted i literally requested
i love that you did this for my birthday
i told my i called my executive
producers
please okay i love nathan i want the
whole cast i was like please get them on
my show i love that you did it for my
birthday do you all have so much fun
with each other because i know not every
set can be like that magical with
chemistry we do
we do have a lot of fun and sometimes
you're such a hard ass i love it yes
okay sorry go
to the extent that when we're waiting
between takes and we're all hanging out
we're taking too much time to get back
to set because we're talking we're
laughing we're playing games we play a
lot of games you play games feel bad for
the directors because they come in and
their job is to you know get through the
day get through all of their scenes but
they usually have to add on like when
we're all there at the same time they
have to add on like an hour to the day
because they know that we're going to be
talking playing games it can be a bit of
chaos yeah this is kind of the right
scenes with us together anymore we used
to be in the roll call room all the time
and if you notice as the seasons go
we're not in there as much anymore
because we don't uh complete our days
yes oh my god is like me and my friend
mary from childhood we they separated us
young they were like they won't actually
shut up
yeah but social um so what are
everyone's most memorable birthdays i'll
start with you nathan
my most memorable birthday uh oh god
start with somebody else please please
okay anybody right off the bat my
favorite birthday was when i turned 30
and uh my grandmother had recently
passed and i heard this word wow i'm
really going deep i heard this word i'd
never heard before hyperion and i was
like i'm going to look this up and
hyperion is one of the tallest redwood
trees and for that birthday i found it
but you have to like geo-locate it and
it's not on a trail and so i was like
wading through this river totally clear
you can see all the way to the stones
like carrying my sack over my bag what
kind of movie are you living in right
now what a good one that's amazing
and you found it i know that's amazing
are you that kind of person you're
always like adventurous like that yeah
who doesn't love redwood trees i love i
am a nerd
i love them
it's more of an illusion
okay now you have to one-up redwoods
eric what's your favorite birthday it's
on my 27th birthday i planted a redwood
tree
and um
i turned 37 i climbed it and built a
house up there and i
planted
what did you do you've had enough time
sir yes i forgot all about it uh i had
gone nearly a decade without having a
party i had forgotten and someone said
it's time you have to have you have to
have a party it's kind of stressful it
can be yes yes yes but i had someone say
i'll take care of all the arrangement
and i rented a restaurant yeah i had
like 350 people there okay
barbra streisand showed up
who also has my birthday we're both
april 24th don't worry about it happy
birthday barbara happy birthday byra you
and i we're birthday sisters
there's so much in common um that's
amazing why is she randomly her
wonderful husband came and played my
father on castle i don't know if you
remember that do i remember yes so he
was invited he brought along his lovely
wife and there they both were
[Applause]
i love that your dad ended up being like
that was so amazing thanks again for
coming i'm so excited thank you so much
i'm so excited you're all here um so
what's been your favorite okay there's
so many
how do you it's it's amazing like the
show like it go and i love this about a
show i feel like you love this about
shows too because i've seen you in a lot
of them but it's like so diverse the
show will touch on such emotional i mean
the part where you were like almost died
and then the part with the relationships
your ex like there's like there's so
many
so many layers do y'all like that the
fact that you each get i
i feel like writers on sets or on shows
don't always pay attention to all the
characters i just want to give a shout
out because the writers it really is
important that the writers like
you really like dive into all the
characters because you lose so much
opportunity there and there's an
individual story for each whatever
cultural background or whatever gender
like all of that i will say i was always
surprised like for example she was
pregnant last year and so she had a lot
of they allowed her to have a lot of
days off yet her character story was
still really big you didn't miss her at
all yeah and they're really really good
with that i don't know how they do that
when with such a large cast how each
character is is equally important yeah
yeah i'm kind of smirking because my
sister had a full-on conversation about
how much we loved your character
pregnant your emotions
i was like i love the writers who are
making you like it's a really beautiful
thing you just said nobody was freaked
out because you're nice
where else do you go you can't go like
more negative with her so they just no
it was amazing it was so funny um so
alyssa so is there some story about a
banana peel that's what i'm supposed to
ask oh so the banana peel story so
whenever nathan has a banana
he grabs banana peel and he throws it on
the floor like like a cartoon like
someone's gonna slip on it but
apparently i'm i think the only one he
doesn't in front of
you thought this was like a thing you've
done
i just tossed on the floor i go hey come
here a second and just push like but i
put it between us i go hey just come
here a second that's all that's all i do
that's literal do you pick it up
okay
before we go to break i need to
congratulate you on season five
i love y'all so much for doing this show
i literally texted my brother i was like
please get them on my show and i love
that it was for my birthday you know
something that's been brought to our
attention you're no stranger to
television work we've actually been
partying we've we've seen your work
your acting work i hate acting on
sabrina the teenage witch
wait that was paying attention
in my defense my roommate was an actor
there it is here we go here we go who's
that who's that yeah that's me that's me
you know what that is that's fifty
dollars
first of all you're extremely talented i
love how you're looking right down the
barrel right at the camera
that's amazing
that takes a lot of courage that takes a
lot of courage supposed to be looking at
her but we would we think that if if you
would do us the honor of taking some of
that talent and bringing it to our show
oh my god are you serious you guys i'm a
horrible actor can i just walk by and do
this
can i we're going to find you something
you're really good at yeah we're going
to find yourself have me playing kelly
clarkson i'm really really bad at acting
okay i'm sweating right now
but i'm totally in just so i can hang
out uh time for another commercial break
everybody you can see the rookie sundays
on abc or streaming anytime on hulu in
my living room
[Music]
you